en este vídeo vamos a ver la estructura
del ojo y lo vamos a hacer dibujando una
sección transversal del mismo lo primero
que voy a dibujar es la parte blanca del
ojo se llama esclerótica que es un
tejido fibroso grueso qué forma
prácticamente el cuerpo del ojo y sirve
para protegerlo así como punto de
anclaje para los músculos que permiten
el movimiento de los ojos para poder
observar lo que hay a nuestro alrededor
así que esta parte blanca es la
esclerótica imaginemos que esta es la
parte de adelante del ojo y esta es la
parte de atrás cuando vemos a alguien lo
vemos en esta dirección lo primero que
vemos es algo llamado córnea la córnea
es transparente por lo que no podemos
verla sirve básicamente para proteger la
parte frontal del ojo y también para
desviar un poco la luz que pasa por ella
vamos a etiquetar la córnea la córnea es
muy sensible y necesita estar protegida
por una delgada capa de células
epiteliales llamada conjuntiva esta capa
delgada de células epiteliales
protege a la córnea de fricciones de
manera que cuando nos frotamos los ojos
no lastimamos la córnea además la
conjuntiva ayuda a mantener húmeda la
córnea y protege del polvo y otras
partículas extrañas cuando vemos el ojo
de alguien tenemos la córnea y lo
siguiente que hay y que no podemos ver
es el humor acuoso que está detrás de la
córnea imaginamos esto como una cámara
llena de líquido y ese líquido se conoce
como humor acuoso el humor acuoso es
básicamente agua salada y rellena esta
cámara anterior del ojo ahora imaginemos
que por aquí entra un rayo de luz y ya
mencioné que la córnea desvía un poco
este rayo de luz y la siguiente parte a
la que llega este rayo de luz es al
lente o cristalino el cristalino se
encuentra aquí atrás es un lente be
convexo lo que significa que es curvo en
ambos lados de manera que cuando un rayo
de luz llega al cristalino se va a
desviar un poco más el cristalino puede
cambiar de forma puede hacerse más
delgado o más grueso dependiendo de si
el objeto que se observa está
o está lejos y lo que hace que el
cristalino se vuelva más grueso o más
delgado se conoce como el cuerpo ciliar
el cuerpo ciliar está compuesto de
varias partes un conjunto de ligamentos
que se conectan en el cristalino y se
llaman ligamentos suspensorios estos
ligamento suspensorio están conectados
al cristalino y también a los músculos
ideales vamos a etiquetarlos estos se
encuentran a ambos lados del cristalino
y estos ligamento suspensorio si los
músculos ciliares son lo que hace que el
cristalino pueda cambiar su forma y en
conjunto se llaman cuerpo ciliar que
además produce el humor acuoso que vimos
aquí así que la córnea desvía un poco la
luz y el cristalino la desvía aún más
algo interesante es que cuando vemos
bajo el agua todo se ve borroso esto es
porque cuando la luz es emitida en el
aire vamos a dibujar un sol muy contento
por acá de manera que cuando el sol
emite un rayo de luz que pasa por el
aire cuando llega a la córnea se desvía
un poco pero cuando estamos bajo el agua
el aire es reemplazado por el agua y la
luz
de forma diferente aquí es como se
desvía cuando hay aire y acá es como se
desvía cuando hay agua es por eso que
vemos las cosas borrosas bajo el agua
porque los rayos de luz no convergen
donde deberían hacerlo cuando usamos
gafas de natación imaginemos que las
estamos usando aquí bajo el agua lo que
hacen las gafas es agregar una capa de
aire frente a la córnea de manera que
cuando la luz llega a la córnea se
desvía de forma correcta y no de esta
forma anormal como lo hace cuando hay
agua en lugar de aire lo siguiente que
vamos a ver es algo llamado iris el iris
es la parte del ojo que tiene color si
alguien tiene los ojos azules o verdes
es porque el iris está pigmentado de
forma diferente el iris está compuesto
de dos músculos diferentes que se
contraen y expanden y cuando lo hacen
cambian el tamaño del hueco que está
aquí haciéndolo más grande o más pequeño
esto lo etiquetamos como iris
este hueco se conoce como pupila sé que
he escrito muchas palabras pero créanme
que todo tendrá sentido cuando termine
de dibujar el diagrama completo la
pupila es el término para referirse a
este hueco cuyo tamaño está controlado
por los músculos del iris si afuera está
muy oscuro queremos que el hueco se haga
más grande de esta forma entrará la
máxima cantidad de luz a la parte
posterior del ojo y cuando hay mucha luz
afuera queremos que el hueco se
contraiga para que entre menos luz al
ojo y pueda enfocarse realmente en lo
que está mirando la luz llega al
cristalino y es desviada y luego pasa
por algo llamado humor vítreo el humor
vidrio es lo que llena la cámara
posterior del ojo de aquí acá es la
cámara anterior y de acá a acá es la
cámara posterior y en la cámara
posterior del ojo está conformada por el
humor vítreo que es una sustancia
gelatinosa compuesta de sales agua y
algunas proteínas de las cuales la
principal es la albúmina el humor vítreo
ayuda a sostener el cristal
y no y mantenerlo en su lugar así como
proporcionar cierta estructura para el
ojo de manera que el ojo no colapse
sobre sí mismo también es transparente
de manera que la luz puede pasar a
través de él una vez que el rayo de luz
llega a la parte de atrás del ojo
alcanza una estructura llamada retina la
retina cubre toda la parte posterior del
ojo la retina está compuesta de muchas
células diferentes llamadas
fotorreceptores las cuales toman este
rayo de luz y lo convierten en un
impulso nervioso que el cerebro pueda
entender la retina tiene un color rojizo
y es por eso que cuando se toman fotos
en la noche y se usa flash los ojos
salen con un tono rojizo lo que sucede
es que al salir el flash los rayos de
luz llegan a la parte de atrás del ojo y
rebotan en la retina lo que es captado
por la cámara causando lo que se conoce
como efecto de ojo rojo algunas cámaras
tienen algo que reduce este efecto de
ojo rojo lo que hacen es encender dos
flashes el primero sirve simplemente
para reducir el iris
hacer que la pupila se haga más pequeña
y el segundo flash sirve para tomar la
foto cuando las personas tienen la
pupila más pequeña de manera que se
reflejan menos la luz en la retina esto
reduce el efecto de ojo rojo la retina
envía fibras a la parte de atrás del ojo
de manera que estas fibras puedan llegar
al cerebro estas fibras forman algo
llamado nervio óptico aprovechamos para
etiquetar esto como retina las fibras de
la retina forman el nervio óptico que
llega al cerebro donde la imagen tendrá
sentido ahora vamos a hablar de la
siguiente estructura que se encuentra
detrás de la retina y es una membrana
llamada coroides la coroides es
básicamente una red de vasos sanguíneos
que nutren a las células de la retina y
otras células del ojo la coroides es de
color negro y es por eso que al ver los
ojos de alguien cerca de la pupila lo
vemos realmente oscuro porque estamos
viendo la coroides que está pigmentada
de color negro en otras especies como
los gatos la coroides no tiene pigmento
de manera que brilla lo que
ayuda a tener una mejor visión nocturna
pueden imaginar que llega un rayo de luz
de este lado y en los humanos si este
rayo de luz no es absorbido por la
retina será absorbido por la coroides
que es de color negro el color negro
absorbe la luz pero en los gatos es
brillante así que la luz es reflejada
por la coroides y llega de nuevo a la
retina de manera que ésta la absorbe
entonces la retina tiene dos
oportunidades de absorber la luz lo que
mejora la visión nocturna de varios
animales como los gatos entonces la
coroides es una red de vasos sanguíneos
que está pigmentada de negro
quiero señalar una característica más de
la retina es un hoyuelo que se encuentra
aquí y está lleno de conos estos conos
nos permiten ver algo con gran detalle
esto se conoce como fobia y se encuentra
en el centro de una región más grande
llamada mácula la mácula es un nombre
anatómico para una región particular del
ojo y en el centro de la mácula está la
fobia donde hay muchos conos que nos
permiten ver algo con grande
estas son todas las estructuras del ojo